[APPLAUSE]
>> If you could be any superhero,
what super power would you wanna have?
I bet you are thinking
about it aren't you?
Well growing up, believe it or not,
this was something my friends and
I would think about a lot.
We'd get really excited and we'd say
things like, I wanna fly like superman, or
I wanna be able to read
10,000 words a minute
as our parents started to listen in.
My answer though was always consistent.
I wanna make people laugh.
At this point you might be wondering,
how is that a superpower?
I would argue that it is.
Growing up,
my father was a professional comedian, and
I was always fascinated, because he could
get away with pretty much anything.
You can ask my Mom.
I wanted to be just like him.
As it turns out, I'm in business school,
so that didn't quite work out.
But I learned an even bigger lesson,
that humor can actually teach us serious
lessons about how we can
better relate with each other.
Lessons I didn't quite set out to learn.
In fact, my dad didn't set
out to be a comedian either.
20 years ago he moved back from
the United States to his home country,
Ghana, after studying acting
in the United States.
It was a pivotal time in Ghana's history.
For the first time,
we had democratic elections after two
decades of a military dictatorship.
It was a time of a lot of excitement.
A lot of hope, but yet
that necessary dose of skepticism that
newly democratized countries tend to have.
And my father could be pretty stubborn
when he was convinced of an idea.
And he was convinced
that the only way this
democracy would work is if we talked
openly about what was not working.
So to make his point, he goes onto radio.
And of course, the first thing he does,
is publicly criticize the government.
As you can imagine,
that didn't go down too well.
Public reaction to him was intense.
His car was vandalized, people wrote
him some pretty creative hate mail.
And the sponsors actually
pulled out from the show
labeling him as overly controversial.
Fast forward a couple years later.
He returns to his first love,
which is acting.
So, he performs in his first one man play,
originally set out to be a drama.
But the audience actually
ended up laughing so
much that it was written about as one of
Ghana's best comedy plays of all time.
[LAUGH]
>> And that is how he became a comedian.
Why am I telling you this story?
It's because in that play
he spoke about the exact same issues
he used to talk about on radio.
This time though,
people drive more than five hours,
line up, and pay just to listen to him.
That, ladies and gentleman,
is the power of humor.
That is why I think it's a superpower, and
that is why I wanted to be just like him.
This fascination with the power of humor
stayed with me through the years and
I actually ended up
working in the industry.
I worked as a producer for a comedy show.
I learned some pretty hard
lessons very quickly.
The most important being, I'm not funny.
[LAUGH]
>> In fact, when I told my
brother that I wanted to make people laugh
for a living, he was quiet for a minute,
looks at me, and says,
I've laughed a lot because of you.
Does that count?
[Laughter.]
>> So I took a different approach.
And I sought to understand
what it was about
humor that enables us to let our
guard down and connect so instantly?
And what I found through my research and
my work, is that the magic of
humor is that it's unexpected.
In fact,
our brain works with pattern recognition.
So, basically, when you hear a story, you
subconsciously try to auto-complete it.
But when the story goes
in a different direction,
we experience this rush
from the surprise factor.
Humor works because we delight
in the unexpected when it's
coming from a good place.
Research shows that our brains
pleasure center actually
is far more reactive to experiences
that are both pleasurable and
unexpected than experiences
that are simply pleasurable.
It's the reason why surprise wedding
proposals work so well, most of the time.
[LAUGH]
>> But how does this connect us?
Well think back to
the last time you laughed.
Hopefully that was a few minutes ago.
Think about how you felt towards
the person that made you laugh.
When we experience this rush,
our brain captures and
holds that emotional memory, so
the next time we meet again,
we associate this positive memory with
the person and warm up more quickly.
In other words, if you make a guy or
girl laugh on the first date,
you're probably gonna get a second one.
So, we know how humor connects and
affects us, but
not all of us can be professional
comedians, try as we might.
And as I've learned to ask
myself in business school,
how do we apply this framework of using
unexpectedness to delight each other?
Better yet, how do we scale its
affect in our everyday life?
And I'll tell you a quick story that
helped put it all together for me.
A couple years ago, I lost a bet
to one of my good friends, Sarah.
And like all our bets,
I had to buy her lunch.
And so I'm standing in line, I've put
in my order, I'm ready to pay, and
to my embarrassment,
I've left my wallet again.
And then the weirdest thing happened.
A guy walks from behind me, swipes his
credit card, pays for our entire meal and
walks away before I can
even say thank you.
And I'm standing there completely
surprised, but also delighted.
And over the years,
with similar experiences and
as I've tried to pay it forward,
I've come to realize that yes,
we can delight each other in small,
unexpected acts of kindness.
Think back to the last time that
you received words of encouragement
from a friend you hadn't heard from in
a while, or a friend you just made.
Or a time a complete stranger let
you have that first parking spot.
That may be a little too much to ask in
the city but hopefully you get my point.
We can all tap into what makes
humor a super power by going
a little out of our way each day for
the people around us.
Even if it's as simple as turning
to the person next to you and
saying something thoughtful.
You look nice today, even.
In this world,
we're often encouraged to think big.
To think of impact in terms of touching
the next million or billion lives.
Yet, in our own personal lives,
we think we're touched by individual
moments, and individual people.
So, my challenge for you today is to
think small, but make it unexpected.
You'll be pleasantly surprised.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]